[Music]
right Dean destroyed Trump left-wing
media is no longer content with just
attacking the president now they are
stooping to really insane conspiracy
theories what do I mean
take a look does Russia have some kind
of leverage over Donald Trump in a new
cover story from New York magazine
writer Jonathan Chait argues we have not
allowed ourselves to consider the full
range of possibilities chant lays out
what could be considered the worst case
scenario for Trump Russia collusion the
Donald Trump has been a Russian
intelligence asset since 1987
1987 is when he he went to Moscow and
he's feted by the Russians and mentors
Moscow and then he comes back then he
starts talking about running for
president for the first time and then he
starts talking for the first time about
how our allies are a bunch of
freeloaders and we should kick him to
the curb
so it really dovetails with Russian
foreign policy interests then and now
now again that's probably a coincidence
but it might it might not be okay
Russian asset okay now these bizarre
conspiracy theories even extend to
trumps Supreme Court nomination again
back to yes NBC News Tom Brokaw are you
proud reporter had to delete this tweet
claiming the president and Justice
Kennedy had conspired to select judge
Brett Kavanaugh joining us now the
author of the book why we fight Fox News
national security strategist dr. Gorka
and Fox News contributor Daniel Hoffman
dr. korkor it's really simple okay he
was an asset since 1987 now we figured
it out but today he basically was
telling Germany don't rely on Russia
which if they didn't would tank Putin's
economy in a year Sean I can play their
game too so all the people you showed
all the staff members at the New York
Post Washington New York Times
Washington Post CNN MSNBC I don't have
any evidence but I think they're lizard
men from another dimension it might be
true I don't have any evidence this is
journalism today they're like cornered
rabid rats they've been selling us lies
for so many years
that now they can't go any further
except to double down because if they
did anything else down on it definitely
admit to us but they'd have to admit to
us that they've been lying so they just
invent new stuff Daniel Hoffman this is
your business this is what you have done
including Russia as working as a CIA
operative I don't even know what to say
about this it's basically everything
they say you just can't trust any of it
anymore
dr. Gork is right it's all lies it's all
driven Sean this started with John
Brennan who did a great disservice to
the national debate on national security
by openly speculating without evidence
that Vladimir Putin could blackmail the
president now Brennan later retracted
his speculation but the damage was done
and Brennan should have known really
that he speculates an in peril and if he
had something to say he could have gone
to the special council but he really
framed the debate and and that's what's
great greatest concern to me was just
his absolutely unprofessional and very
partisan behavior it's even actually
worse than that I mean and I'm not I'm
not even joking I mean Tom Brokaw spent
his life and I don't think he agrees
with Sean Hannity but people like Tim
Russert this is not NBC News any more
doctors Walker this is a whole new
entity which is basically innuendo
conspiracy theories outright lies faked
news and an agenda to destroy the
president D legitimize him and it's been
going on for two years three years
actually let's let's do what they do so
let's take Daniels really important
points so John Brennan isn't Joe Sixpack
he's the former director of the CIA and
he leaves government service still has
his clearances I don't know why he
hasn't been stripped of his clearances
goes on but he didn't evil he was a
communist wasn't he he voted for gas
hole in 1976 the Communist Party
candidate for president and then was
hired by the CIA
incredible can he go he goes he gets he
gets picked up as a contributor on
left-wing media he's
what daniel said about the president
being vulnerable and then he's basically
doing putin's work for him let me let me
play the game may do Sean
it's John Brennan getting paid by Putin
to spin this I don't have any evidence
short but it could be that's right the
president a what the president was
saying to Germany is don't rely on Putin
and be so dependent on him considering
we're spending all this money to
possibly deal with the hostile Russia
and if in fact Germany listen their
economy is done because that is their
economy so the president doesn't seem to
be too bold in the Vladimir Putin
tonight yeah my my late father used to
tell me to be faithful to the facts they
won't steer you wrong and I think it's
important for viewers just to parse out
those facts you're talking about Sean
that's what matters it all right guys
unbelievable times we're living in fake
news at its worst